so to illustrate what I want you to do
is we need to draw some pies okay I want
you to draw what compared not these
numbers we'll come back to these in a
second I want you to compare two
different numbers so I'm going to do a
little something okay now I want to
simplify it for you I'm going to give
you two fractions of the pie which
hopefully you'll be able to tell me
immediately which one is bigger I'm
picking them as an example because you
know right so that we can illustrate the
concept and then come to something you
don't know
so when I write these down to just shout
out which one's the best one because I'm
picking it could some obvious example
I'm gonna show you the process of how to
order these fractions and then we'll
have a look at this where it's more
tricky okay so here are the two
fractions then I'm gonna give you a
choice off or 3/4 now hopefully you can
see which one is bigger because you're
familiar with thirds and you're familiar
with quarters but how can we be sure
right not just like oh I think it's that
one just experience tells me how can we
mathematically demonstrate it okay and
this is where I want you to help me by
drawing some pies okay so I didn't you
come but maybe right underneath this I'd
like you to draw for me um two rows of
three pies let's just look at a top down
because that will make it easiest now
each of these rows okay they correspond
to one of these fractions okay
so we're gonna make this the two-thirds
options and we're gonna make this the
3/4 option
now have a look at this with me and it's
important you have them set up like this
okay let's think about the two thirds
one two thirds now how would we divide
this song accurately into thirds okay I
want you to remember back we did some
work on angles didn't we
angles remember those so just up and say
you don't need to uh draw this but okay
if you have a full revolution how many
degrees is that that's 360 degrees now
if I were to divide that into three
equal parts
I take 360 degrees I divide that up and
I get 120 for each section okay so I
could you know the parameters can make
you Joyce exactly but I reckon you can
draw it pretty close I want you to draw
the center of a circle
stick it in there and now let's try and
define something as best we can in two
equal sections so I'm guess you'd be
simpler so I have divided up my ply into
thirds yes good now by the way it will
it will help if you have them other
colors there but if you don't just do
some cutting or shading to do now I'm
gonna shade two-thirds of the pie okay
let's do that
let's shade two-thirds there's one and
there's two
good looks good now let's do the same
for three-quarters but obviously because
it's quarters not thirds
I'm not going to divide the circle like
this we come back to our 360 degrees you
divide that by 4 to get quarters how big
will each sector how people that's angle
B if you divide by 4 you'll get 90 so
they should all be right angles [ __ ] in
there okay so let's draw that in
okay so there's my center of the circle
right where they are where those two
lines meet and there are all of my
quarters in a circle they're also called
quadrants by the way but shading your
three quarters as well so there's my
three quarters okay and so now in case
it wasn't already obvious before you can
see which one is a better deal okay but
number one we want to be able to show
that mathematically not just with the
picture and number two we want a way to
do this they'll will work with these
like I don't know how to divide up a
circle nicely into 70s where as thirds
and quarters are quite easy right even
fix the sevenths up into a challenge so
let's watch what happens now what I want
remember we said you know introduced
they're really easy to compare some
fractions are really easy to compare as
well for instance if I took all of these
numbers and divided them all all by 4 so
if I had 1/4 2/4 even though they're
still fractions they're very easy to
compare much easier than these all these
why why aren't they easier to compare
hmm saucy aha because the denominators
are the same I can just compare them in
the same way that I have these because
they're all the same denominator better
word for them a better phrase for that
is that the fours are a common
denominator that's an important phrase
to have okay a common denominator common
this is what we want if we can get a
common denominator between our fractions
whether there's 2 or 3 or 300 then we
can order them we can compare them for
order
now how do we do it okay
well for starters what I want you to do
first is I want you to redraw the same
divisions that you had for the two
thousand three quarters draw them on the
next circle but we're going to add some
new stuff onto it
okay after you've done that so divide it
up just like you did before this is
still gonna be thirds okay
and this is not still gonna be points
here okay now I'm gonna do this twice
what will let us get a commented on out
I'm gonna do a what's visually and then
I'm gonna do it numerically I'll write
the numbers out he's all we gonna do I
should have one I should have shaded the
two-thirds okay now in order to have a
comparison between them okay
see these thoughts every third here one
two three I'm gonna divide these thirds
into quarters
I'm gonna divide these thirds each one
into quarters so that there's thirds and
quarters in the same diagram so watch
right for instance have a look at this
empty one over here okay to divide up
into quarters I will divide it up in
half and then I'll harbor heart so now I
have four quarters of the third okay so
let me say that again I took that third
and I divide it into course I would do
the same thing for the other two as well
Johanna just leave it okay there's one
at one more here we go there you go now
you can see why I did it in a different
color so you can see maybe if you don't
have a different color you can just make
these lines pick up okay I divide it up
every third into quarters now have a
look how many sections do I have now how
many sectors rather I have well because
there were three four and they've all
been divided before I've got one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve twelve so this one here is
divided by 12
how many sections are shaded you can cut
the country one two three four five six
seven eight okay a turtle now remember
what we looked at yesterday what are
these two in relation to each other they
are leagues equivalent fractions
remember Frankie's head over top now I'm
gonna do the same thing down here right
but these quarters what do you think I'm
going to do I'm going to buy them into
thirds to buy these quarters into thirds
okay so watch I'm gonna get my other
color out of here divide that one into
thirds
that's pretty close divide this one into
thirds this one into thirds and the last
one now just like I did before I now
have twelfths you see that you see I
twelve sixteen twelve here how many are
shaded
sweetiepie
okay what get to play so okay well
what's our last pi/4 okay here it's a
bit sort of unclear I just want to have
the twelfths in place so you can see
what I end up with okay so here's what
I'm going to put in there we go okay so
what I got here I've got the same
diagram I've got the same diagram all
the way along okay but here it's just
twelve right let me let me shade those
in okay there are the eight toes okay so
what I want you to have on this final
diagram just shows you what you actually
got and it disguises the process we went
through to get there this is sort of our
final answer we can compare okay and
we'll do the same thing down here to
fear there we go there's the toss
wonderful okay so there we go now
remember I said I was going to do it two
ways I was gonna do visually that's
that's visually there what have we done
numerically how can we write it out okay
well to get this right remember I
divided a thirds into quarters so what
that is really is maybe aren't mean all
right over here this actually have space
that's two thirds right i divided up
this into quarters right but that gave
me more sections that got shaded four
times as many four types of many shaded
parts four times as many tutor parts
right and that's what gave us a twelve
here I divided the quarters into thirds
so I had three over four to start with I
had when I divided up into
third time three times as many shaded
parts and three times as many total
parts which is one egg I now have a
common denominator just like I had here
and now you can see it's super super
obvious eight nine this is the better
deal assuming you like the kind of pie
that I'm serving okay